this is the car Jaguar are putting their
money on in the words of its CEO the
British car make is not just betting the
house but an entire skyscraper on its
success the XE is smaller cheaper and it
intends to go up against germany's
best-selling cars CEO dr. Ralf Speth
himself a German is taking jag in a new
direction now this guy's really of the
car for the young gender is with the
younger generation and we hope to
attract more younger buyers but also to
attract more females the XE was flown
above the streets of London over the
weekend and unveiled last night at a
lavish show in the capital complete with
pop stars the cars unveiling is quoted
by one Sunday newspaper at costing 4
million pounds to put on but that small
fry compared to the overall investment
dr. Spath says jag is pumping 3.5
billion pounds in the year through March
to broaden the company's lineup we have
at the moment only a very very limited
product portfolio wall is only offering
top end performance engines
that changes now the new jag will be
priced on par with a BMW 3-series at
between 23 to 45,000 pounds depending on
extras for Jaguar the XE is about
joining rather than beating the
competition